yo I'm Daniel and this is your first
time here welcome to my channel consider
subscribing and also clicking the
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos now this is a video
request a lot of you guys asked me to
give you skincare tips on how to get
clear skin so I'm gonna give you guys 7
tips to get healthy clear skin let's not
waste any more time let's get right into
the video
[Music]
all right now we're not girls right so
we don't need to do a thousand things to
get healthy and clear skin but there are
a few things a few habits that you need
to pick up on and do to get and maintain
healthy clear skin so let's start with
the first one the age that we live in
it's pretty common sense but you need to
eat a healthier food our research shows
that the food you eat impacts not only
your face but your overall appearance as
well so food rich in vital nutrients
like vitamins key minerals omega fatty
acids fish oil protein and antioxidants
will help your skin to look better think
about it if you eat crap you're gonna
get crap I'll make a dedicated video for
you guys about the best food that you
can eat for your skin but just to
mention a few you gotta eat more healthy
vegetables nuts fatty fish avocado seeds
sweet potatoes soy and stay away from
sugar bad oils bad carbs like bread and
actually most unhealthy processed foods
alright this move on
probably doing it right now stop
touching your face
I got a few guys right yeah you got to
stop touching your face I mean through
the day you pick up a lot of germs and
then you touch your face all over with
that dirty hands and there it goes into
your pores and that's not what you want
think about it what do you do with your
hands the whole day well almost
everything right and how many times do
you wash it yeah that's another tip you
can wash your hands a little bit more
all right let's move on to the next tip
probably know this already but you got
to drink more water wait a second what
do you need to drink more water while
drinking around a glass of water a day
will help your body to get rid of those
toxins and anything else that shouldn't
be there a man's skin just like a
woman's needs daily care to look clean
and healthy as the years go by you don't
need a hundreds of products but you do
need a basic skin care routine and
doesn't take a lot of time and effort
first you need a good water-soluble
plans that will clean your face from all
that oil and the third that you've been
picking up throughout the day or when
you wake up in the morning you sleep and
your body produces sebum and it produces
oil and it blocks your pore so you need
to wash it you need to wash all that
gunk off then after the face wash you'll
also need a good moisturizer that will
really give your skin what it needs to
stay fresher smoother and hydrated as
well but to get a better result you need
a nice exfoliating toner you got to use
it right in between the facial wash and
the moisturizer it makes a huge
difference because it removes all those
dead skin cells that clog your pores and
you're to use the pores as well and the
redness if you use the right exfoliating
toner so it's very important to use the
right skin care products because there's
oh my goodness there's a lot of products
out there that's actually very bad for
your skin products of drying ingredients
like menthol alcohol as well as skin
aggravating ingredients like peppermint
witch hazel and eucalyptus so what are
the best products out there did you
trust well I've tried a lot of products
over the years but by far my most
favorite piecee for men it's a trusted
brand that brings much needed honesty
into the skincare world if you get it
you'll get good results but there's also
other options like Clinique rocket and
DAPA vision Hanley and Brickell and just
like always I've added those products
for you in a video description so it's
easier for you to go and check them out
into your own research never ever just
believe whatever a youtuber says that's
why I add those links for you guys in
the description you can go and do your
own research read the customer reviews
on them as well alright let's move on to
the next to sleep you got to get more
sleep I've also said this in a few other
videos but if you look like dehydrated
and kind of dull it's a big sign that
you need more sleep when you sleep your
body starts to repair itself more and
that includes your face as well try to
get around 7 to 9 hours of sleep if you
get less than 6 it's definitely gonna
affect your appearance
[Music]
you gotta stop popping and just
scratching out those pimples especially
if they're big and if they swollen you
don't want to do that especially if you
don't know how and when to do it why
well because they can cause acne marks
and worse permanent scars now I get it
sometimes you have that special event
and then you have a zip pimple here and
it's ugly and is huge and it just came
at the wrong time and then you're gonna
pop it and you're not gonna listen to me
or anybody else right but there's a way
to do it maybe I'll make a video a
dedicated video for you guys on how to
do it at the right time as well but
using a good skin care routine will
really help you out and you'll get a lot
less pimples but now and then will
stress a lot of things you might get the
odd pimple or two now if you struggle
and if you have very bad acne I'll add a
few good products for you new video
description down below that will really
help you out
stress less yes you got a stress less
because stress creates a lot of problems
if you stress your body creates these
hormones like cortisol and that can
create pimples and even worse breakouts
so find ways that will help you to
stress less and how to cope with
different situations that might give you
more stress remember 99% of the things
that we think will happen never happens
and he's not the stress that brings you
down but it's your reaction to that
stress if you liked the video give it a
thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you in
the next video
cheers guys